[MUSICAL NOTES]
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: I want
to start by telling you
what it's like to be
at boarding school
and get a parcel in the post.
Now this is not something that
happened to me very often.
So when at the age of
15, a small package
arrived with my name
on it, it was literally
the most exciting
thing of the year.
I remember it so clearly,
the box, the brown box
with my name on it.
Half a dozen or so of my best
friends, all really excited.
We're still in our pajamas
because the post arrived
after breakfast, everyone
jumping on the bed,
"Open it, open it!"
because they were sure
there'd be sweets,
there'd be chocolates
for everybody to share.
So there I was.
I turned over the box
ready to break the seal,
but something stopped me.
The writing on the back
looked cold, unfamiliar.
I read it with despair.
Her Majesty's Prison
Service, Holloway, London.
Anxiety choking
me, I tentatively
opened the box and a
pile of letters cascaded
to the floor, all with this
same familiar handwriting on it,
my handwriting, all
addressed to one person--
Mum.
Is there anything
more devastating
when the moment when
something you've
been trying to
hide and hide from
reveals itself for all to see?
There was a letter inside.
Dear Caroline, your mother
is no longer in our custody,
so we're returning
your letters to you.
Yours sincerely.
Devastating.
According to the children's
charity Barnardo,
the UK charity, children of
offending parents, parents
who spent time in
prison, are twice as
likely to have mental
and misconduct problems.
They consistently
underperform at school,
and they're three times
as likely to end up
being offenders themselves.
Growing up as a black
kid, as a daughter
to a mother who
was barely there,
to parents who never
lived together, let alone
were married.
As the sister to siblings who
themselves were constantly
arrested, to a sister who
had a teenage pregnancy,
all her children taken
into foster care.
Being cousin and
niece to relatives
who valued teenage pregnancy and
state dependency more than they
valued achievements, education.
Aspiring to succeed, to
do well, to be secure,
to be free in that
environment was
a battle of extraordinarily
difficult odds.
My name is Caroline Flanagan.
As you've heard, I'm a
coach, I'm a speaker,
and I'm an author.
But I am extremely passionate
about empowering people
to fight and win
battles they think
they have no way of achieving.
That day I opened the box,
I discovered a secret,
the secret to toppling
giants, to winning battles
that you think you have
no chance of winning.
And it's the single
most important factor
in my journey to date and
every success I've achieved.
Getting used to
scrolling down here
because the clicker
isn't working.
It's also the single
most important factor
in helping me to succeed as a
mother of four fantastic boys.
This picture is amazing.
Not just because it
shows my lovely boys,
but to have all four of
them in the same picture,
still for long enough
to take the picture
and actually looking at
the camera and smiling,
is nothing short of a miracle.
Dylan, Noah, Luca, and Maxwell.
Today I want to share with
you the secret to fighting
difficult battles and winning.
That secret is this.
No matter how hard
the challenge,
how strong your opponent, or
how daunting the circumstances,
you can win that battle
if you do one thing--
if you focus only on
what you can control.
Focus your attention on
Balance is definitely a battle.
It's hard.
It's so hard, in fact,
we almost don't even
talk about it anymore.
I find when I go in to meetings
and I talk to my clients
about balance--
and particularly corporate
clients, they say no, no.
It's work-life integration,
working agility.
No one's talking
about balance anymore.
I feel like, have
we killed it off?
Is it something that's
so hard to achieve
you decided to just brush
it under the carpet?
Just for fun, I did a Google
search on work-life balance is
dead--
5.6 million results.
I didn't look at them all,
but certainly the first page
was all about the end
of work-life balance.
It's a battle of
extraordinary odds.
Why is that?
The way I see it, there
are three reasons.
The first one is that work-life
balance is quite difficult
to define.
Can anyone give me
a quick definition
of balance, work-life balance?
You don't have to
prove me right.
If you've got the
perfect definition,
then please come forth with it.
Anyone?
Anything come to
mind immediately?
AUDIENCE: To find an
equilibrium between two forces.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: To find an
Brilliant.
Balance, in other words.
But what does that
mean in real life?
AUDIENCE: To spend as much
time on your personal life
as going to work.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: To
spend as much time--
for those of you who didn't
hear-- on your personal life
as you do on your work life.
Thank you for that.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Al.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN:
Al, thanks for that.
That's pretty
good, pretty clear.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Meeting your
work and your own goals.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: Meeting
your work and your own goals.
Excellent, thank you.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Neru.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: Neru?
Thank you, Neru.
This is a snapshot
of a conversation
I had with a client
early on this year.
So you want better balance,
better work-life balance.
What does that mean to you?
What does it look like?
My client-- well, I want
my life to be balanced.
So I'll feel much more balanced.
Me-- OK, so let's dig
a little bit deeper.
What does it actually look like?
On a day-to-day basis,
what are you doing?
Client-- well, at home,
I'm doing all the stuff
that makes me feel balanced.
And work-- yeah,
work's balanced.
Yeah, I know I've
got work-life balance
because I'll feel balanced.
That conversation
is surprisingly
typical with my clients.
It's quite hard to
define, and I think
Al and Neru did a very
good job of coming close.
Now this is a problem
because as research shows--
as you would have almost
certainly have heard--
if you want to achieve
goals, it really
helps if they're smart goals.
So they're specific,
they're measurable.
They are achievable, they're
realistic, they're time bound.
Research shows
that that increases
your chances of succeeding
in achieving a goal.
And it also shows that
if you can write down
what your goal is,
you can articulate it,
that increases your chances
of succeeding even more.
When was the last
time you sat down, you
wrote down your specific goals
for having work-life balance?
Lady in the pink who
answered the question first.
Ever?
Anybody ever do that?
It's hard to define, and
that makes it even harder
to achieve.
The myth of work-life balance.
The second reason why it's so
hard to achieve, no one size
fits all.
What works for me just
might not work for you.
You may prefer to work
from home five days a week,
but perhaps your preference is
actually to be in the office
those five days, get all
the work done so that you're
much freer when you're at home.
And just to complicate
things more,
if you have children, what works
for you when your children are
really young won't necessarily
work when they're older,
when they're teenagers.
So what does this mean?
It means we have to create
our own personal solution.
We can gather together all
the different components,
the productivity apps and the
time management strategies,
and the well-being routines.
But the important bit is how
we bring all of these together.
And there's no universal
blueprint for that.
You have to find our own way.
So the third reason why
balance is difficult,
and arguably the
biggest, it's just
the nature of the world we live
in and the way we work today.
All those wonderful
technological advances
that have brought
so much freedom,
connected us in ways we
could never have dreamed of,
even 50 years ago.
They've all come at a
price, haven't they?
We are always on,
always connected,
constantly working,
constantly moving.
And of course, the demands
of our working environment,
competitive, the importance
of performing or proving
your value, competing
against our peers.
And add to that what's
going on internally.
This is the battle,
the second battle.
This is the two
fronts, what's going
on on the outside
with work environment,
but also internally, our
inability to restrict,
control how much
we use technology.
We've become slaves to it.
And add to that, even
our feelings of I'm
an impostor, impostor
syndrome, perhaps.
Or just your innate need
to achieve, to progress,
your innate ambition.
All of this conspires
to make it very hard
to walk out of the
office, switch off
completely, and enjoy
the bits of your life
that don't involve work.
I want to tell you
three stories that
underline my message
about how you
can win this battle for balance,
a battle which, as I've just
explained, is a difficult one.
It's a battle against the odds.
It's the 28th of August, 1963.
Martin Luther King,
leader of the Civil Rights
Movement in the 1950s
and 1960s in America,
he's standing on the
new Lincoln Memorial.
There are 250,000 civil rights
supporters there in the crowds.
And he delivers
this iconic speech.
I have a dream.
For those of you who don't know
or recall what that dream was,
it was a dream for equality.
It was a dream for a day when
the children of black slaves
and the children of
black slave owners
would be able to go to school
together, be treated equally.
It's hard to imagine a more
challenging battle than the one
they faced at that time.
This was the period of Jim
Crow, of state-sponsored
discrimination and aggression.
It was the time of lynchings,
of the Ku Klux Klan.
It was the time when segregation
in hospitals, on transport,
in schools was
completely normal.
And yet, 1964, the Civil
Rights Act was passed.
In 1965, the Voting
And although discrimination
continues today,
the battle for equality goes
on, particularly in America.
There is no doubt that those
two bits of legislation, which
made it illegal for people
to be treated differently
because of the
color of their skin,
they were iconic victories,
defining moments,
and an incredibly
important battle.
How did they do it?
How did they win?
Four things stand out for me.
First of all, they had a vision.
That's what's so powerful
about this speech, the "I
Have a Dream" speech.
It was rousing,
it was motivating.
It didn't focus on how difficult
and impossible that vision was
or that dream was.
It focused on what that
dream would look like.
And I urge you to
go back and watch
the footage of
that speech, and I
challenge you not to be
completely inspired by it.
So the vision was there.
The second thing that stands out
for me is they were prepared.
So they had a strategy of
how they would do this.
And this involved
non-violent protests
in the form of marches,
sit-ins on public transport.
Non-violent protest
was only ever going
to be met with violence.
And that's the key
to their strategy,
was actually saying
not just this
is what we want, this is
how we plan to get it,
but anticipating what
the challenges would be,
what obstacles they would face.
And those obstacles
were really very real--
violence, being thrown in jail.
Martin Luther King
was arrested 29 times.
They were ready for that.
In fact, they actually
trained in how
to cope with violent aggression
and how to stay peaceful.
In other words,
they were prepared
and they practiced the
skills that they would
need to further their cause.
And they kept on.
Every time they were
arrested and then released,
they would continue their fight.
The second story I
want to share with you
is a story from childhood, the
story of David and Goliath.
Is everyone familiar
with that story?
Hands up if you're not familiar
with the story of David
and Goliath.
Great, so you all remember the
story of David and Goliath.
It's from the Book of Samuel.
And it's the story about
this fierce giant, Goliath,
and how David, a small,
innocent shepherd boy
with a single slingshot
was able to topple, to kill
this terrifying warrior.
And so win the battle for his
people against the Philistines.
Now it's hard to imagine
a more intimidating foe
or daunting prospect.
How in the world
did David do that?
What was his secret?
Was he just lucky, really?
With one slingshot?
This is the subject
of a fantastic
book called "David and
Goliath" by Malcolm Gladwell.
And in it, Gladwell
seeks to challenge
our perception of what makes
us strong, what makes us weak.
People and things
we think would give
an advantage, and
those things that we
think make us disadvantaged.
And what's wonderful about
the David and Goliath
story, if you read
behind the headlines,
is David, that small,
weak shepherd boy,
he knew exactly
what he was doing
when he went to face Goliath.
He knew that Goliath
was this big warrior,
that he would be decked out
from head to toe in armor.
On the day in question,
he carried a spear.
Goliath carried a spear, he
had a sword, he had a shield.
He was there in all his glory.
David knew this.
He knew that Goliath
would be slow
because his armor was heavy.
He also knew that Goliath was
short sighted because Goliath
had said, where are you?
Where are you?
Show yourself to me.
The other thing that
David knew was that he
was an excellent slingshot.
He was very good at his skill.
This is a skill he used
everyday to protect
his sheep against predators.
He knew that that skill
perfected was enough in one
shot to topple the giant.
That's what happened.
The third and final story
I want to share with you
is the story of Victor Frankl.
Victor Frankl is a
Holocaust survivor.
He died a few years ago.
But he wrote a book called
"Man's Search for Meaning,"
which is one of the most
extraordinary books I have ever
read, and I highly
recommend you read it.
It tells the story of his
experience in concentration
camps and his
fight for survival.
It's hard to imagine
circumstances
that could weigh more
heavily against you,
the torment, the horror,
the misery of being
in a concentration camp.
How did Victor Frankl
and the very few
that managed to survive
when millions didn't, how
did he do that?
What made the
difference between those
who kept fighting,
fighting to stay alive,
and those who didn't make it?
And this question,
answering this question,
is the subject of Frankl's book.
And he came up with one thing.
Despite everything
that was taken away,
everything physical,
the emotional torment,
there was one
thing he discovered
that could not be taken.
And that was his
attitude, his mindset.
He realized the power of
his thoughts, thoughts
that he could control no matter
what happened on the outside.
He would always remain
in control of those.
And that is what he
attributes to his
and many of the others survival
in those awful circumstances.
So those three stories have
the following in common.
They are all examples
of people who
faced extraordinary odds, people
who wanted to fight the battle.
They are stories of people
who won against those odds
because they focused not on
the impossibility of the task,
how powerful and overwhelming
were the odds against them.
They focused on what
they could control.
Focus your attention on
what you can control.
I've already explained
to you that that
was an instrumental factor in
my journey from then to now.
There's just one small problem,
small blip in that journey.
If only I'd remembered
that lesson,
that lesson that I learned
all those years ago
when I was a working parent.
When I returned to Cleary
Gottlieb, which is the law firm
I was working in when
my first son was born.
Dylan was six months old.
And I returned
full of enthusiasm,
positive, determined to make a
success of balancing my career
and my new family.
Wow, that was.
The first year of
being a working parent
was the hardest
year I've ever had.
I struggled.
The demanding hours,
the competition,
the air of competition, the
culture of presenteeism.
That awful feeling is
the only non-partner,
non-male who was there,
who had a child, who
had to leave the office and
run and be there for her child.
That feeling when I got home,
despite being exhausted,
despite having to
log on and keep
going with my work and all the
pressure I was under at work.
The feeling at home and
had to learn the ropes.
coming to grips with being
a mother for the first time.
And I was doing
everything at home.
My husband-- who I'm happy
to say is much better trained
now--
at the time, his
career, his life
remained surprisingly unimpacted
by the arrival of our new baby
boy.
It was the hardest
year of my life.
I fought very hard,
but I struggled.
What was my strategy
in those circumstances,
in that really hard battle?
I had no strategy.
I was just too blind to be
able to even spot the things
I might be able to
control, let alone focus
my attention on those things.
I went from day to day, my head
in a spin, putting out fires.
That's what I did.
I had a year of just
putting out fires,
always exhausted, always
stressed, always worried
that I'd forgotten something,
that I was underperforming
in all these different areas.
Is it any wonder that that
battle ended in failure?
When my second son was
born, I walked away
from a career I had
been leading up to,
spent my whole life
building, for all the reasons
that I hinted at at
the beginning of this.
It took a lot for
me to walk away.
I thought I was powerless.
Alice Walker, Pulitzer Prize
winning author and poet.
And she said, "The
most common way
that people give
up their power is
by thinking they
don't have any."
I know I felt
completely powerless
when I was trying to
juggle my legal career
and getting used
to being a parent.
But it turns out, I
wasn't powerless at all.
The book that many of you
are holding in your hands,
I wrote that because
I wanted others
to learn from my failure.
My failure was to
become your success.
And the whole purpose was to
show you that you are powerful,
that if you focus your attention
on the things you can control,
you can succeed.
I was at a lunch, a business
awards lunch a few weeks ago.
And I found myself
sitting next to a partner.
She's a partner at KPMG.
And it turns out, she's been
playing rugby for the England
rugby team for
about 15 years now,
but she's recently retired.
And we got onto this
subject of where
you focus your attention,
how people succeed,
what holds people back.
And she said, yeah, of course.
She goes, that's
absolutely right.
Control the controllables.
What?
She said, control
the controllables.
That was our mantra the whole
time I was in the England team.
That's what we did.
We knew we could do nothing
about the size, the reputation
of the opposition.
We couldn't do anything about
the weather, about the pitch,
even about the mood of the fans.
So we put our head down.
We focused on our training,
our attitude, our mindset,
our preparation.
And that's how we
went into our matches.
And that's how we won.
Control the controllables.
Don't you just love that?
I wish it hadn't been the
mantra of the English women's
rugby team because then I
could've had it as mine.
But it sums it up
just beautifully.
And that's exactly
what I'm doing now,
what I've been doing
for the last 10 years.
I am controlling the
controllables in my life.
From the time I wake up
in the morning and what
I do when I wake
up in the morning--
to how I get to work,
what I do on my way
to work-- to what I
say yes to, what I
say no to, who I say
yes to, who I say no to.
What I think about at
the beginning of the day,
what I think about at
the end of the day.
There are an infinite number
of controllables in your life.
And your only job
is to control them.
And that's how I'm winning.
I'm not winning very well at
scrolling down on my laptop,
so bear with me.
What does this mean for you?
How is that useful?
How can this be practical?
I want to introduce you
to The Babyproof Method.
Just adds suspense.
It's disappeared and hopefully
it will come back again.
The Babyproof Method is
quite simply a framework
that I've created to help
my clients do exactly that.
Know where to focus
their attention,
know what the controllables
are, and what they can do,
how they can control those
in a way that helps them
win the battle for balance.
There are four steps involved.
Step number one is
all about the picture.
Remember I started talking
about defining balance,
knowing what that was?
Have a really clear
picture in your mind
about what balance looks like.
It's not enough to
call it balance.
It's not even enough to
say it's an equilibrium.
It's not even enough to say
it's the same amount of time
at work or at home.
What is your ideal version of
balance right now, for you?
Until you are able to
answer that question,
the best tips in the world are
not going help you get there.
Remember Martin Luther
King's vision, his dream.
You need to dream in a
vision of that intensity
if you have any
chance of succeeding.
But it's not just
about the dream,
it's also about making
that dream come alive.
So if you're living your
ideal version of balance,
you are there for three out
of four of your child's school
activities.
You are leaving
work at five o'clock
at least two days of the week.
You down tools, turn your
phones or technology off always
at eight o'clock.
Whatever your version
of balance is right now,
you also have to have,
in your mind's eye, what
might get in the way of that.
What are the obstacles
you might face?
And crucially, how can
you prepare for those?
How can you prepare
to meet them?
Which is step number two
in The Babyproof Method,
is to prepare.
Preparing is all
about asking yourself,
what can I do now,
what can I build now
that I will need when the time
comes, that I will need later?
The best way of
describing this is,
I often use the metaphor
of running a marathon.
Nobody wakes up
one day and says,
I'm going to run
a marathon today.
What they do is
they say, I'm going
to run the London
Marathon in April.
And they probably
say, wow, OK, I'm
going to have to
do a lot of stuff.
That's quite daunting.
Oh, that's quite a big task.
But they know.
And if they do the
right training,
they get the right support,
and they practice, by the time
that day comes, they're
going to be prepared
not just to succeed,
but actually to enjoy it
if they've done the work.
And this is what The
Babyproof Method is all about.
Having that picture
I talked about,
seeing yourself
running that race
if you were running a
marathon, running that race
and enjoying it.
The preparation is
the bit, whose support
are you going to need?
And it's the same with
the battle for balance.
Whose support do you need
to get better balance?
Is it your partner?
Is it the support of your
boss or your manager?
friends, of your mother-in-law?
Whose support will you need,
and how will you get it?
The third step in
The Babyproof Method
is to practice the skills.
Think of David.
He didn't show up to face
Goliath ready to throw
a slingshot for the first time.
It takes practice
to become an expert.
And the good thing is,
if you do practice,
you will become an expert.
So the practice step is
all about looking at,
what skills am I going to need?
Very simple.
I'm going to need to
be extremely organized.
I'm going to need to be very
good at knowing what to say yes
to and what to say no to.
I'm going to need to be very
good at looking after myself.
What's my strategy for
keeping myself healthy--
mentally, physically?
All really specific,
very tangible skills,
things that you
can be doing that
make all the difference
in the battle for balance
that require practice.
They require you to
get good at them.
And in the fourth and final
step in The Babyproof Method
is perseverance.
How do you persevere?
How will you keep going?
When, not if, when
you reach a point
that you want to give up, when
things seem like they're too
hard, that inevitable moment--
Martin Luther
King, the 29th time
he's arrested, how does he
convince himself to keep going,
to keep trying?
Victor Frankl, how does
he, despite everyday
all the evidence
to the contrary,
convince himself that it's worth
fighting for, to keep going?
Picture, practice, prepare.
Picture, prepare,
practice, persevere.
This is something I
do with my clients.
And I've created
an online course
to take that all over
the world, so people
can access this
process that is so
empowering in a way that
fits in with their lifestyle
and really easy.
And I'm really
excited that Google
is going to be piloting
this course sometime
in the new year.
And I think Kristi's going to
talk a little bit about that
at the end.
She's disappeared, but
she'll be back to do that.
But back to the present.
What can I give you?
What can I leave
you with that you
can start doing right from the
moment you leave this office?
So I've got one
suggestion for you.
It's just one controllable that
I want you to experiment with.
Getting up early.
What time do you all get up?
What time do you get up?
You're all having
a nice chuckle.
What time do you get up?
AUDIENCE: 7:15.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: 7:15.
What time do you get up?
AUDIENCE: 6:00.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: Six o'clock.
What time do you get up?
AUDIENCE: 9:30.
AUDIENCE: When my
daughter gets up, which
could be five or four o'clock.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: Five o'clock.
Five o'clock, four o'clock.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: 5:30.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN: 5:30.
It's a competition now.
5:30, 5:00, 4:30.
AUDIENCE: Eight o'clock.
CAROLINE FLANAGAN:
Eight o'clock.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Whatever time that you
ordinarily start your day,
I want you to get
up one hour earlier.
This is the goal.
We're going to start
with a smaller challenge.
We'll start with a
smaller challenge
and explain that in a moment.
Getting up early, I love it
because everybody gets up.
We all make a decision about
what time we set our alarm for.
how many times we press snooze.
How many snoozers?
Raise your hand if
you're a snoozer.
Are you sure?
Are you being honest?
Hands up if you're a snoozer.
Yeah.
At least 50%.
I wrote a blog about
getting up early.
It has been undoubtedly
the most successful blog
I've ever written.
It has so many downloads it's
unbelievable, which shows me
it's touching a nerve.
And I called the blog when I
first posted it, "Never Press
Snooze, Ever."
And it had such a brilliant,
and in some cases,
quite strident reaction to it.
But it got people thinking
because right from the moment
you start the day, it gives
you that sense of making
a decision, making a decision
about what time you get up.
Getting up early is a
controllable for everybody.
Let me tell you just three
of the many reasons why
for me, it's one of the
most important controllables
in my life.
The first one is it
gives me me time.
That essential time
at a time in the day--
in fact, the only time in the
day over which I could have
control.
It means even if that me time
is 10 minutes, 15 minutes,
I have time to think about
myself in a way that prepares
and allows me to be
available for everybody
else for the rest of the day.
It is a me time
that is so sacred,
that on the odd occasion
where I think, oh, I'll
lie in tomorrow, that
voice my head says,
how could you do that to me?
How could you take away the
most important bit of my day?
You can ask my husband,
it drives him mad.
I have got to the point where
it's so beneficial to me,
I'm almost incapable
of lying in.
It is so powerful
and important to me.
The second reason
is it's a moment
in the day, everyday, where
I can have perspective
on that day, on my week.
I can look with some distance
and say, what's working?
What am I doing today?
What have I been doing in
the last few weeks that's
working well for me,
that's making me feel good
like I'm in control?
And what's not working?
What is it that
I need to change?
And it gives me that
moment of reflection
to come up with solutions, to
come up with different things
to try.
And trust me, you create the
space for solutions and ideas.
Hey, that's what
you guys do here,
we create space for
ideas for innovation.
You will come up with solutions,
different things to try.
And the third and
final reason, it
helps to keep me connected
with the big picture.
So hard to remember
the big picture
when you're busy all the
time, completely working hard,
overwhelmed, being stretched
from one task to the next.
The big picture is just the why.
Why are you doing this?
Why do you have a family?
Why do you care?
Why are you still working when
you know that you would also
like to be with your family?
What does work give you?
And connecting with
that on a regular basis
makes all the difference when I
turn around to my six-year-old
and I say, I can't
come to this event
today because mommy's got to
go and do this piece of work.
But don't worry, when I
see you at the weekend,
we'll do X, Y, and
Z. And I do not
feel guilty about
the number of things
that I say no to, because in
my head always is a compass,
is the big picture, is the
life I want for my children,
for my family, and for myself.
There are just three of many
reasons why getting up early
is such a powerful
controllable feeling.
And I want you to
experiment with it yourself.
So I want to set
you a challenge.
I've called it The
30:30 Challenge.
Super easy.
Whatever time you get up,
even if it is four o'clock,
set your alarm to get
up 30 minutes earlier.
But there are rules--
no work.
This is not a license to
extend your working day.
That is worse than lying in
bed until the last minute
and pressing snooze.
No one, no devices, no news.
Sounds so simple,
very hard to do.
But it's a skill.
Practice.
30 minutes earlier for 30
days, the next 30 days.
This is my challenge to you.
What will you do with that time?
Look at the big picture.
Think about the week
you've got coming up.
What's working,
what isn't working?
What could you change?
What could you do differently?
Controllables every
step of the way.
Good luck and let
me know how it goes.
[APPLAUSE]